good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight was almost
two years ago during the democratic
presidential primaries that kamala
harris appeared on cnn
to explain where she stood in the race
now at that moment harris had
just been memorably and completely
humiliated
by tulsi gabbard of hawaii during a
televised debate
so she needed to explain what had just
happened here's what she said quote
i'm obviously a top tier candidate
harris said
and so i did expect that i would be on
the stage and take hits tonight
now if you're following the race at that
moment you're chuckled because in fact
kamala harris was not
a top tier candidate not then not ever
not since the day she actually announced
now on paper she had seemed like a very
serious contender she was a united
states senator from the country's
biggest state
she was a former prosecutor who enjoyed
nearly universal support among
washington post reporters
and msnbc anchors so it seemed for a
while like it could work why wouldn't it
work
well here's why the problem was actual
voters found her repellent we don't need
to guess about this we have the numbers
the more kamala harris they got the more
repelled they became
by december harris was losing to andrew
yang in her own state
the majority of california democrats
primary voters
said they wanted her to drop out of the
race harris was even getting crushed in
iowa a tiny state where she had spent
virtually all of her money so
even in a business that is famous for
rewarding falseness
kamala harris was just too phony to win
she was too
fake for politics so the question is
how did kamala harris wind up
effectively in charge of the entire
country
that's a question that historians of
democracy will spend decades pondering
democracy being you'll remember from
school
a system in which citizens get to choose
their own leaders
yet apart from a few handlers around joe
biden nobody really chose kamala harris
it's a pretty amazing story actually
it's frustrating
but it's also deeply amusing so take a
moment
once in a while just to pause a respite
to enjoy the
pure hilarious absurdity of miss kamala
d harris you will find it refreshing
so this is a fully vaccinated person who
recently kissed her fully vaccinated
husband
while both of them wearing surgical
masks and then pretended it was entirely
normal just like you do at home
kissing your vaccinated husband with a
surgical mask this is the daughter of
two college professors
who tells you with a straight face that
she grew up poor and depressed
under jim crow in california this is a
person who can't stop lecturing you
about american values what this country
stands for
despite the fact she didn't really grow
up here actually harris went to high
school in montreal and yet and this is
the amazing part
even in french-speaking canada she now
tells us
quote many generations of her indian and
jamaican family
somehow celebrated kwanzaa that's a
holiday that was invented in los angeles
in 1966 and we could go on but let's
summarize it for you
how fake is kamala harris we'll put it
this way
she can't even decide how to pronounce
her own first name
we've heard her say it at least two
different ways with maximum confidence
imagine being her what would your life
be like
well among other things you'd be
terrified at any moment of being pulled
off script
because once you were off the script
what would you say
how would you know you don't even know
who you are something like that
just happened when harris spoke to her
friends over at nbc news
watch this do you have any plans
to visit the border at some point you
know
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole
this whole this whole thing about the
border we've been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
i've never been to spain but i kind of
like the music i don't understand the
point you're making
of course she doesn't understand the
point no one ever
asks her real questions when was the
last time that happened tulsi gabbard
was probably the last
person to do it and in almost two years
since
harris has continued to ascend how'd she
do that well purely on the basis of how
she looks
meanwhile because it is so improbable
that
someone this unimpressive has become so
powerful
the people in charge are forced to
assure us almost with hysteria
that she is brilliant and impressive
in order to prepare the rest of us for
her inevitable march to the white house
they've had to create a soviet-level
cult of personality around her and we're
not exaggerating look around
the la times which was a news
organization at one point announced that
harris was getting her
own section in the newspaper that is
news dedicated exclusively
to kamala harris readers get their
business news their
international news and then their
critical kamala harris news she's now
her own category of news
the paper called the new section
covering kamala harris
not surprisingly the first dispatch from
the la times's new kamala harris bureau
didn't focus on her policy
accomplishments that would have been a
pretty thin
segment section instead the paper
covered the way she looks
quote kamala harris is all kinds of
firsts
the first woman the first woman of color
the first black woman the first
mixed-race woman and south asian elected
to national office
so in other words what really matters
about kamal harris and what should
matter to you
according to the new york times is her
dna it's really kind of a science
project
disney went further than that kamala
harris disney explained to your kids
recently
isn't actually a political leader she's
more than that
she's like a god once there was a young
girl
who used her voice to make the world
around her a better place
some say the odds were stacked against
her but her mother had big plans for
this little flower
who had freedom fighting in her blood
she led a successful protest
so kids could continue to play and
became part of a divine group of leaders
she rose to places that no woman had
from front lawn activist to madame vice
president
she will use her voice to run this
nation and
inspire it too kamala harris making
her story
next time you see someone walking across
the top of your swimming pool it's
probably kamala harris
she became part of a divine group of
leaders
divine in the literal sense like the
dalai lama or king
kim jong-un she shot an 18 in her last
round of golf
now kamala harris does have a kind of
appealing humility so she doesn't
compare herself to god she prefers the
superhero analogy
in fact her own book is called
superheroes are everywhere that's the
book that
wound up at the migrant detention
facility recently
if you haven't seen it or if you're
looking for more kamala harris books
there's a whole assortment
you can get her niece's book that's
called kamala and maya's big idea
what's the idea we couldn't find it and
if your kids are interested and of
course they are they can buy the
quote youth-oriented edition of kamala
harris's ghost written memoir
and of course because why wouldn't there
be we now have
kamala harris-themed food in this case
baked goods apparently made by the
united states military
on our way to guatemala this weekend on
the plane kamala harris walked to the
back to hand out cookies not just any
cookies not oreos
not fig newton's cookies in the shape of
kamala harris
one usa today reporter who was thrilled
excitedly snapped a picture quote
the vp made a visit to the back of the
plane and delivered cookies decorated
with the shape of her likeness
so kamala harris isn't just a vice
president she's a star
she's a major historical figure indeed
she's god
and if you say that enough you tend to
kind of believe it that's where media
find themselves they believe it
unquestioningly
so as she headed to latin america this
weekend they had the highest possible
hopes
from the night that kamala harris made
history as the first woman
the first person of color elected vice
president she made clear that winning a
seat at the table
was just the first step and her highest
profile assignment so far
a solo trip to guatemala and mexico this
weekend to tackle the root causes of the
surge in migration
the symbolism of having a mom a mom of
color up there
talking you know about these situations
i think it is important
the child of immigrants first black
first south asian woman
is going to represent us in guatemala
today i mean i
would really kill to be a fly on that
wall in those meetings
remember she is the first woman vice
president she's the first woman of color
vice president
and this trip will start to shape how
americans view her
the fact that kamala harris is visiting
there is the first
woman female vice president the first
woman of color
to visit that region herself a child of
immigrants that speaks volumes as well
to the people of those countries
well in addition to everything else
she's a mom now we didn't know that
but most to the point really the nub of
the theme here
is that she is a quote person of color
so when a person of color goes to latin
america to be around other quote
people of color it's a love match
they're going to love
kamala harris in latin america it's
obvious that's how our credentialed
class
thinks people of color love people of
color unfortunately for kamal harris
that is not actually how latin americans
think latin america is not america latin
america is a traditional society
people in latin america are still
allowed to their great credit to say
obvious things they haven't been trained
by their leaders to censor their
unapproved thoughts so sometimes they
just go ahead and utter them
as kamala harris found out yesterday
when she arrived in guatemala
her motorcade was mobbed by protesters
not trying to get her autograph or buy
her superhero books
but telling her to get the hell out of
their country kamala would go home read
one placard
another sign near the presidential
palace this one really hurt read this
kamala trump won
now to a certain kind of liberal this
was shocking and some of the press pool
seemed shocked by it
but they shouldn't have been shocked
guatemalans of all people know what
political corruption looks like because
they live in a corrupt system and they
looked up to the united states and they
saw the presidential election wasn't
exactly on the level because it wasn't
they knew that all the powerful people
in the u.s were on one side
joe biden's side and so they trusted the
outcome less
and then they said it and by the way and
this maybe hurts most of all and msnbc
is gonna have a lot of trouble digesting
this
but it's true some guatemalans actually
support donald trump
and that doesn't shock people who've
been paying attention
who does your average guatemalan have
more in common with let's be honest
kamala harris or donald trump come on
it's not even close among other things
latin america to this day is still a
vigorous patriarchy
so it turns out that gender bending
academic postmodern feminism
doesn't make sense there it's totally
confusing to your average campesino
they think it's absurd and they're right
it is
so in guatemala it's pretty hard to sell
kamala harris as a god
if kamalier says look and be treated
like god she ought to go to london or
some other population center where
people hate themselves and hate their
own culture
that stuff doesn't work in central
america the white house should have
known that the state department too
isn't this their job but they didn't
know it because it turns out that in
addition to being hard-edged ideologues
which they are
a lot of these people are actually
pretty incompetent they're not quite
sure what they're doing and you can tell
by watching carefully
they're flying blm flags from american
embassies
around the world why are they doing that
so people will love us
but in real life no one outside america
is impressed by a blm
flag outside the embassy in fact they
think it's pathetic
why because it's an intentional
self-conscious display
of weakness and guess what no one on
earth actually respects
weakness if you wanted the world to like
you
you would show strength you might fly
the gazdan flag
don't tread on me people in guatemala
would get that
they'd respect it they might even like
us more
you know what they don't like cringing
self-hatred that's disgusting to them
and to most people it's a feature of
human nature it's universal
now tony blinken is the secretary of
state you think he would understand that
he's america's top
diplomat apparently he doesn't at every
opportunity he self-flagellates
in front of the entire world here's a
selection for the united states to be a
credible force for human rights around
the world
we have to face the realities of racism
and hatred here at home
we can't sweep our shortcomings under
the rug or pretend they don't exist
we need to face them openly and honestly
even if that's ugly even if that's
painful
that's how we live up to our values
it's not painful for the rest of the
world to watch a [ __ ] like tony blanken
talk about
how terrible american is is not painful
it's laughable it's ridiculous
the administration sincerely believes
the rest of the world deeply appreciates
when we get up and beat us ourselves up
for sins that
took place a hundred years ago they
think
central americans are impressed by our
blm
flags no they're not impressed and
they're not impressed by kamala harris
they just laugh and tell us to go away
brit human hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else